[Music]
this is the story of the decontamination
efforts conducted jointly by the
pennsylvania health department and the
united states public health service
during the summer of 1964
at lansdowne pennsylvania
this duplex frame house in the quiet
residential section of lansdowne is
unique because its basement is
contaminated with radium
painstaking follow-up of old records and
alert action by the pennsylvania
department of health revealed that the
former owner a university professor
processed radium in the basement during
the 1920s and 30s
preliminary alpha readings depicted in
red on the floor plan were in excess of
one million disintegrations per minute
per 60 square centimeters
average alpha levels were in the
hundreds of thousands disintegrations
per minute
gamma readings were approximately one
milligram per hour three feet above the
floor of the basement
auto radiographs made on sheets of
conventional x-ray film of sections of
floors
and walls show the patterns of
contamination
each dark spot on the film was produced
by a speck of radium
a large dark splotch shows where the
radium had been spilled on the concrete
floor
knowing the patterns of contamination
appropriate plans for decontamination
could be made accordingly
the kitchen was established as the
control point
the hallway to the basement separated
the clean from the contaminated areas
personnel were suited with plastic
coveralls on top of cloth coveralls
surgical caps were worn under plastic
hoods
surgical gloves were worn under rubber
kitchen gloves rubber boots covered the
shoes
masking tape was used to cover all
openings
during the decontamination operations
different types of protective clothing
were tested
full face masks supplied with compressed
air were worn by decontamination
personnel working in the basement
air samples were taken continuously
note the two types of masks
a scott pressure demand regulated type
on the left and a free flow type on the
right
alpha and beta gamma surveys were also
made continuously
instruments and notebooks were protected
in polyethylene bags
after removal of household goods the
entire basement was cleaned with a
cambridge vacuum equipped with an
absolute filter
the hose and handle were covered with
strippable tape
vacuuming proved unsatisfactory however
because the large volume of dust soon
clogged the filter
test samples and autoradiographs
indicated that the radium was sandwiched
between layers of paint
and the chipping was required to remove
the contamination
note that the ceiling was covered with
plastic sheet to confine the
contamination
the debris was collected in 55-gallon
drums
low-level wastes were sorted out and
subsequently disposed of in accordance
with commonwealth of pennsylvania law
the dust was hosed down and squeegeed
into a sump from which the wastewater
was pumped into a 55-gallon waste
treatment tank outside the house
the floor scrubbing treatment proved
ineffective and later the concrete floor
was also removed by chipping
waste drums were packed sealed and
sorted prior to their shipment to a
high-level waste disposal site in new
york state
personnel monitoring was conducted
throughout the project and also included
nose wipes urine analyses
and the use of film badges and pocket
dosimeters
at the end of the project
decontamination personnel exposures were
considerably less than one-half the
permissible occupational exposure
contaminated clothing was collected in
polyethylene buckets for disposal
contamination had spread to the outside
area during the years that the professor
had been processing radium
surveys made with an alpha monitor a gas
proportional counter revealed activity
on the order of a few thousand counts
per minute
and further decontamination was not
considered
necessary the thin mylar window of the
probe was approximately 440 square
centimeters in area and proved effective
in covering large areas quickly
barely detectable traces of radium were
found on adjacent properties and
presented no significant health problem
gamma readings were taken with a gm
survey meter at the surface and three
feet from the center of each drum
an estimated 30 milligrams of radium
were collected in a total of 180
55-gallon drums
and properly disposed of
the united states air force also
cooperated in this project by providing
the loan of a radio chemistry trailer
laboratory containing internal
proportional counters and a satellite
alpha counter for checking smear samples
nose wipes and air filters
while the project required over 14 000
man days
the valuable experience gained and the
resulting manual on decontamination of
radium
will be most useful for future training
purposes
[Music]
you